the Seven Commandments fake news come on
if clickbait headlines were not this
would be a masterpiece actively
manipulative cold war style active
measures in the American heartland in
the same techniques the same origin even
the same perpetrators
great production value music
showing in their opinion how Russian
disinformation evolved from the Cold War
to Kanye every agents was evaluated on
for how many proposals for
disinformation operations he submitted
quick disclaimer this is an opinion
piece so you can't bug the New York
Times about factual inaccuracies which
seem to make up the bulk of this series
for one the defected spy that gave the
interview and confirmed all of this
never even worked at the KGB he fled
from Czechoslovakia which wasn't even
part of the USSR Putin started funding
something called the internet research
agency this is serious
said who was the proof how ah ha ha
hold on I forget opinion piece yeah well
you know that's just like your opinion
man the centerpiece the KGB's 7
Commandments on fake news find a crack
and in society create a lie so big
nobody would believe that it was made up
wrap it in a kernel of truth conceal
your hand as if the story came from
someone else find a useful idiot deny
everything and play the long game
inevitably of course we get an honorable
mention isn't it nice to have your own
TV channel Wow
that does it they got us stellar
journalism MIT except you know I have
this nagging feeling this doubt the KGB
playbook that they claim to have exposed
fits one story even better let's do this
properly New York Times Style commandant
one the Kraken society Donald Trump New
York Times's personal arch enemy check
commandment to the outlandish lie Donald
Trump the President of the United States
of America is a Russian spy check
commandment three a sprinkle of truth
everyone knows Donald Trump met with the
Russians he's
being the Moscow checks out commandment
for conceal your hand the anonymous
sources unnamed officials political
experts they all seem to spend more time
talking to the press than doing anything
else
check commandment 5 find the useful
idiot oh come on this is too easy
his opponents will believe anything
about Trump remember the secret dossier
that said he hired hookers to pee on a
bed check commandment 6 deny everything
check we didn't reveal reported CNN or
BuzzFeed did went first I know what CNN
did commandment 7 play the long game
that's what they've been doing the
endless cycle of stories about Russian
hackers oligarchs fake news invasions
aggression it's been long all right all
7 Commandments have been followed and
faith is strong father and fake news
heaven hallowed be thy name your
fakeness come you news be done on earth
as on the Internet
amen
you